du général de gaulle et de monsieur rené
coty ils sont arrivés devant la tribune
officielle et après avoir salué le
drapeau de la garde républicaine
il remonte à bord de leur voiture pour
aller tout au long de l'avenue des
champs elysées jusqu'à la place de
l'étoile et dans l'avenue de la
grande-armée passé en revue les troupes
qui prendront part au défi
au rond point des champs elysées sur le
chemin du retour le président de la
république et le général de gaulle font
redescendre et deux voitures devant la
nouba les tirailleurs algériens et cette
fois le général de gaulle prend congé de
monsieur rené que tu avant de gagner
villacoublay d'où un esso bretagne
l'emmènera directement vers toujours au
général de gaulle assistera à la revue
navale pour l'instant c'est le défilé
aérien avec les vampires mystère et le
final l'apothéose le diffuser trois
faisceaux de fumée bleue blanche et
rouge tracée dans le ciel très bleu ce
matin et 13 minutes parce
et le décider des troupes terrestres
emmenés par des éléments de la
gendarmerie et les membres monte d'abord
que vous venez de voir passer
voici d'autres abordent tracks c'est à
dire de véhicules a hobo trice et demie
chenilles et qui sont les véhicules de
base de n'importe qui portait les armées
modernes et toujours appartenant à la
gendarmerie
les chars
sharp a d'autres pas
c'est à dire charme et charlie plus
lourds actuellement 0,10
un escadron de l'art gendarmerie mobile
voici le général qui couvre le défilé
des troupes blindées
et le 1er régiment de marche du tchad
qui est devenu depuis qu'il a participé
à la libération de paris dans les rangs
de la 2e db qui est devenu l'un des
régiments de traditions de la région
parisienne est également monté à bord
d'art traces
ce régiment avait été l'un des premiers
régiments reconstitué en afrique et
avait pris part à tous les combats de la
colonne leclerc depuis le fait âmes
jusqu'à la france jusqu à alençon
jusqu'à paris jusqu'à strasbourg
le défilé l'église poursuit la caméra
qui vous le montre ici est situé en haut
de l'arc de triomphe
et voici les hôtes ont blindé de
reconnaissance du 2e régiment de
hussards
non excusez moi ce sont les chars patton
les chars patton du 501e régiment de
chars de combat qui est également un
ancien régiment de la 2e division
blindée de la division leclerc et qui
est devenu l'un des régiments de la
région parsienne cantonné à rambouillet
3e régiment d'artillerie coloniale la
prison
et un détachement de la police routière
ces populations entières 602 avec mes
hommes au casque blanc que vous avez
reconnu les casques de la police
militaire
et voici toujours sur quatre axes voici
les chasseurs n'ont pas les chasseurs à
pied bien entendu mais les chasseurs
portait précisément le 2ème bataillon de
chasseurs qui est porteur du drapeau des
chasseurs vous savez qu'il existe pour
tous les bataillons de chasseurs qu'un
seul drapeau dont chaque bataillon à
tour de rôle à la garde est en quelque
sorte le dépositaire
et derrière les chasseurs les engins
antichar téléguidé du 13e régiment de
tirailleurs algériens
c'est gentil chargé des fusées antichars
je trouve qu'il est derrière et l'équipe
est passée
à présent les compagnies sahariennes
porte et trois pelotons de compagnie
saharienne dont les hommes sont
traditionnellement depuis le demandant
la mairie des gardiens du désert et
maintenant ils gardent non seulement de
désert mais gardent également le pétrole
du désert
des batteries tracts et du 1er régiment
d'artillerie coloniale
ses batteries étaient les batteries 255
et voici maintenant un détachement
techniques du génie
un nouveau l'artillerie pièce 255
encore à l'état choix raté
les camions porte grue
le 5e régiment de gym exactement
un régiment de transmissions le 8e
régiment de transmissions qui est le
régiment du mont valérien
et à présent les sapeurs pompiers de
paris qui furent très acclamé ce matin
sur les champs elysées avec leur
détachement dis détachement de guerre
camion perd en kaki et laure détachement
civile dans détachement de paix avec les
camions vin de couleur écarlate que vous
connaissez bien
et pour terminer le défilé des troupes
motorisées les senneterre les ambulances
basse et voici une de nos caméras sur le
sommet de l'arc de triomphe est à
présent précédée de la nouba de deux
noubas même de tirailleurs algériens
celle du 1er régiment et celle du 13e
régiment de tirailleurs algériens les
libanais elle même précédée du bouc
traditionnelle d'une mascotte
voici le dessiner des anciens
combattants d'afrique du nord c'était ne
s'était jamais produit un défilé de 14
juillet de faire décider des civils
puisqu'ils les anciens combattants avec
des militaires les anciens combattants
d'afrique du nord ce que vous allez voir
passer ils sont au nombre de 4000 là en
ce moment la musique
la nouvelle étude intérieure j'ai rien
des voix précisément pour pouvoir ce
camp des pouvoirs scandé le passage d
sans ces combattants le voici
ils sont donc quatre mille venue de
département d'alger venu d'oran venue de
constantine quatre mille anciens
combattants de foot une horde africaine
des sciences européenne environ dans la
proportion de 9 le neuf musulmans au 9
de souche lors d'afrique est ni pour un
euro v
la plupart d'ailleurs de ses anciens
combattants sont des hommes venus du
bled venue d'eduardo des mechtas que
l'on a choisi dans ces régions de
préférence aux villes et vous pouvez
voir que beaucoup d'entre eux portent
d'ailleurs des djellabas apporte des
chèches enturbannés autour du tram c'est
à dire porter pratiquement les vêtements
ce que l'on y rencontre lorsque l'on
circule dans le bled algérien
tantôt aux anciens combattants leur
union européenne qui se trouvent dans
ses rangs ils ont été choisis feu parmi
ceux qui n'avaient que peu d'occasions
de venir en métropole
quoiqu'il y ait plus de parents ni
d'amis soit plus demandé tout simplement
pas les moyens on leur en faire et
terminant se définit les anciens
combattants algériens celui des anciens
combattants du sahara dans leurs
costumes extrêmement caractéristiques
vous allez voir beaucoup mieux encore
voici ce qu'on appelle les hommes bleus
petit porte là pratiquement la djellaba
bio concédé pontalis arc celle qu'il
porte dans le désert
et puis derrière les anciens combattants
d'algérie apparaissent les jeunes
d'algérie 2000 jeunes gens venus des
départements algériens et qui sont
précédées par l fanion et par les élèves
moniteurs de l'école du soir qui forment
précisément des moniteurs les moniteurs
musulmans des moniteurs africains pour
encadrer la jeunesse musulmane
algérienne les trois compagnies
présentes ici de l'école l'islam qui
défilent en treillis bleu roi béret noir
et des jeunes on est jeunes y sont je
crois vous avoir dit 2000 également
originaires des départements d'alger de
constantine oran appartenant pour la
plupart à des mouvements de jeunesse
parfois genre encore beaucoup à
apprendre dans l'art de dessiner les
1ers très content d'être là et je crois
qu'ils ont été encore bobby plus heureux
de l'accueil qui leur a été réservé par
le public parisien extrêmement
chaleureux ce matin coup
également parmi ces jeunes même
proportion environ neuf musulmans
d'afrique s pour un européen
comme je vous disais ils ont encore
beaucoup à apprendre dans l'art de
dessiner mais ce sont des choses que ça
prenne
et à présent les troupes à pied les
troupes à pied et pour commencer la
musique de l'école préparatoire
militaire d'aix-en-provence qui est en
réalité l'école des enfants dit
une compagnie de cette école militaire
d'aix en provence défilante en vareuse
bleue foncée l'airé bleus
et la musique une musique mixte
d'infanterie coloniale vont poser ou par
moitié des éléments de la musique du
régiment de marche du tchad et
d'éléments du 3ème régiment d'infanterie
coloniale
ces musiques précède vie écolo d'autres
épaules j'ai dit à l'instant même
l'école l'ex en provence et voici je
n'ai pas besoin de le préciser
l'école polytechnique
si les mathématiciens les scientifiques
ce qui est une raison supplémentaire
pour qu'en ce qui me concerne je
m'abstienne de commenter davantage ces
images j'en serais absolument incapable
et derrière polytechnique là aussi les
avait reconnus voici casar et gants
blancs et saint cyrien selon laure est
resté bien que le ricol ne serait plus à
saint cyr voici élèves de l'école
militaire interarmes de coëtquidan
la musique de l'école navale de drapés
de l'école navale
mais non mais non c'était bien la
musique de l'école navale c'est
maintenant l'école de l'aer l'école de
salon de provence du pin
et à nouveau des deux mains noires et
des licornes
mais cette fois-ci solutions face du
polytechnicien c'est l'école militaire
de médecine l'école de lyon et pour
terminer l'école de formation des cadres
de la france d'outre-mer l'école de
fréjus et qui prépare ce jugement
parmi les hommes et parmi les
sous-officiers venus des territoires
d'outre-mer qui crée pas des officiers
pour encadrer nos unités d'infanterie
coloniale
à
cette musique était évidemment la
musique de la garde républicaine
qui précède la suite du défilé des
troupes à pied tout à l'heure nous avons
vu les écoles nous allons voir
maintenant les différentes unités
combattantes
la garde républicaine tout d'abord créé
sous l' empire
une première en plaine et les sous le
nom de garde municipal qui se bâtit
d'ailleurs beaucoup à 26 afriyie de
l'ordre espagnoles burgos
un détachement à pied de la gendarmerie
mobile dont vous avez vu tout à l'heure
les éléments motorisés les éléments de
la d6 maintenant les fantassins 17
gendarmes
et à présent la musique du 93e régiment
d'infanterie le régiment traditionnel de
la vendée mais devenu depuis 1946 l'un
des régiments de la région parisienne
ce régiment je veux les dix était
logiquement le vendée c'est dans ses
rangs paire servie durant la guerre de
14-18 celui qui serait un jour de l'an
les fans delattre qui fait vendéen et
c'est précisément le général de la
structure
au lendemain de la guerre après avoir
reconstitué son 93e la prévenir
à paris dont il n'est pas parti fille
elle fut à des régiments témoin de la
nouvelle armée française tel que l'avait
souhaité telle qu'elle avait reconstitué
le général de lattre au lendemain de la
guerre
les musiques des tirailleurs les new bas
le général morlière gouverneur militaire
de paris qui présente les troupes au
président de la république
et la musique à présent du bataillon de
joinville
vous savez que le bataillon de joinville
est un détaillant de sportif dans lequel
les l'athlète l'ex-champion même les
futurs champions de classe nationale de
classe internationale et leurs cadets
peuvent faire leur service militaire
peuvent remplir leurs obligations
militaires sans cessé de remplir leurs
obligations de sportifs
c'est à dire qu'ils subissent
parallèlement une instruction militaire
et un entraînement intensif la caf dans
leur spécialité
elle a cédé officielle à la droite de
monsieur rené coty se trouve monsieur le
trocquer pays dans l'assemblée nationale
et à sa guise il trouve et vous l'avez
aperçu monsieur monnerville président du
conseil de la république est à présent
précédé d'une d'une musique de
l'infanterie coloniale
voici les troupes qui arrivent d'afrique
du nord ancien régiment de marche qui a
été composé d'éléments appartenant à
tous les régiments d'infanterie qui se
battent actuellement en afrique du nord
il y a trois bataillons composants se
résume en trois bataillons dont l'un
représente les troupes de l'algérois
l'autre les troupes puis constantinois
et le troisième les troupes de l'oranais
si bien que toutes les unités
d'infanterie qui sont actuellement
présentes en algérie et qui s'y battent
se trouve en même temps représenté ici
par quelques-uns de leurs hommes
officier de l'ordre policiers triés
j'imagine selon leur mérite car j'ai
remarqué ce matin pendant le reportage
en direct que la plupart d'entre eux
portait à la poitrine
la croix de la valeur militaire qu'ils
avaient reçus lors des combats en
algérie
un régiment de tirailleurs algériens à
présent qui est le premier régiment de
tirailleurs âgées j'ai mon petit se
trouve actuellement également en algérie
pour marquer que les officiers
sous-officiers porte le calot azur
tandis que les hommes portent le turban
blanc traditionnel des turcos comme on
appelle les tirailleurs et yann wehrling
ans
un autre résumant de tirailleurs
également précédé de sa nouba et d'un
book dont je me souviens que les cornes
des pins de couleur d'or c'est le 13e
régiment de tirailleurs algériens qui
est cantonné en allemagne à lambda et la
musique la nuit bas de ces tirailleurs
les hommes de cette loi portent le
costume de tradition des tirailleurs
avec le petit boléro bleus le roi a par
mangeons qui désirent broderie et le
pantalon très très large comme vous
voyez c'est une tenue dont il reste je
crois assez peu d'exemplaires et que
l'on voit très rarement dans les défilés
unitaires
oui
là encore le calot azur a crevé et
gentil et le turban four 10 hommes
hélas une nouba celles qui avaient
scandé le décider des anciens
combattants des boîtes et en même temps
emboîtent le pas aux deux régiments de
tirailleurs qui viennent de décider
l'infanterie coloniale l infanterie
coloniale en l'occurrence le 1er
régiment d'infanterie coloniale est un
régiment dont les hommes et donc les
tambours vous voyez portent l'insigne de
la croix de lorraine l'enseigné français
libres car se résume en fut l'un de ceux
qu ils composèrent la première division
française libre c'est-à-dire la division
de juin 40 pour fabio l'embryon s'est
formé en juin 40
l'individu ayant la division des
gaullistes de la première était
poursuivi ces combats jusqu'à la fin de
la guerre
voici les hommes qui sont les héritiers
des traditions de cette 1ère dfl ya
les tirailleurs sénégalais de fréjus
l'instruction des territoires
d'outre-mer
si vous avez des lourdes et fréjus et se
moquer les spectateurs qui a duck la
région savent qu'on y rencontre beaucoup
de tirailleurs sénégalais et cela depuis
la guerre des talents artistiques
simorre région d'élections pour des
raisons climatiques bien facile à
comprendre
et à présent la musique de la brigade
des parachutistes coloniaux
romaric les parachutistes défilent sur
un pas assez curieux appartenait pas
tout à fait aussi lent que celui de la
légion vous verrez tout à l'heure qui
était un peu roulé un peu traîné un pas
assez décontracté évidemment qui n'est
plus le même pas très vite et a marqué
pour la le mans parachutisme
et voici la légion voici la musique de
la légion étrangère et voici précisément
c'est pas très spécial très lent très
noble de la ministre
la légion si les filles évidemment en
jouant sa marche traditionnelle la
marche du boudin
drapeau du 1er régiment étranger de
parachutistes
qui cette fois a délaissé le béret vert
des parachutistes français pour le képi
à housse blanche qui est lui aussi l'une
des traditions de la légion avec les
épaulettes vertes et rouges
cinq compagnies de la légion étrangère
deux compagnies je crois de même
parachutistes coloniaux
une compagnie du régiment de marche du
1er régiment de marche que la légion
d'une autre compagnie je parachutistes
coloniaux et pour terminer une compagnie
représentant la 13e demi brigade de
légion
la bière ou deux unités d'une fameuse de
la guerre 39-45 puisque je fis la 13e
demi brigade de bir hakeim d'asile
délivrer gap de la dfl occident vision
de la france les la musique des
équipages de la flotte
le drapeau du 1er régiment les fusiliers
marins blindé s'est d'ailleurs les
marais qui normalement et s'il à bord de
chars qui ont combattu durant la
dernière guerre à bord de chars tant
dans les rangs de la deuxième d'aidé que
dans les rangs de la 1re dfl commandos
de la marine
la musique de l'air à présent
des détachements de l'armée de l'air il
complètement quelques sortes
de façon plus visible plus longuement
visible en tout cas le défilé aérien qui
a précédé celui des troupes terrestres
et clôturant ce défilé militaire du 14
juillet 1958 à paris les troupes montées
et dernières troupes montées de l'armée
française la fanfare de la garde
républicaine à cheval de paris
l'étendard de la garde
et la gare
et les spahis le septième escadron de
spa ya lieu
et c'est ce pays clôture se dessiner
militaire est toujours
traditionnellement clôturée par les
troupes navales jeu le président de la
république va maintenant quitter la
tribune officielle
il a félicité le général mourier un
gouverneur militaire de paris qui lui
avait présenté les troupes il y 6 pts et
selon la formule pour la bonne tenue de
ses troupes et le président ayant à sa
gauche que générale gagnent râle
sécrétaire général militaire de l'elysée
va maintenant regagner son palais par
l'avenue marie
ce